and this is a personal practice of mine  i don't tell people about it but i'm  going to share occasionally by myself i  go to the graveyard and i look at those  plaques that has the years the person  lived and check how many people younger  than you are in that graveyard we don't  know how much time we have on earth  there is no guarantee that you're going  to live to see tomorrow but there is a  guarantee that death is coming  up  tells us in the quran that every soul  shall take death that's a guarantee how  long you will live none of us know how  many of your friends have already passed  away i had friends that were 14 15 16  that i buried in my teenage days so  don't put things off you want to be  right with god you want to be on the  right path of the true message because  that's the purpose of your creation the  purpose of life is to recognize and  worship your creator  [Music]